molti pensano che la demografia sia solo
contare persone in base a certe loro
caratteristiche che sia una noiosa la
lista di statistiche come queste in
italia due giovani su tre tra i 18 ei 34
anni vivono con i genitori in svezia la
metà dei bambini nasce fuori dal
matrimonio in niger
ogni donna ha in media sette figli 3,5
per cento della popolazione mondiale
vive in un paese diverso da quello dove
è nata e in effetti visti così questi
numeri forse possono sembrare noiosi
però già meno noiosa è la demografia
quando appare sulle copertine delle
riviste di economia e società nel tempo
a mia disposizione
voglio spiegarvi perché per me la
demografia non è una noiosa lista di
statistiche e perché è importante
parlarne qui oggi
beh innanzitutto la demografia
importante perché ci riguarda tutti
perché parla di noi
gli eventi per noi più importanti nelle
nostre vite sono il punto focale degli
studi di noi demografi nascite decessi
cambi di residenza matrimoni separazioni
per citare i più importanti
provate ad immaginarvi tra vent'anni
quanti anni avrai ti sarai sposato avrei
divorziato
sarei diventato genitore o forse nonno
dove vivrai sarai ancora nella stessa
città se considerati a livello aggregato
questi eventi per noi importanti
diventano i numeri della demografia
faccio un esempio questo è il mio evento
demografico importante
mio figlio giulio che compirà a sette
mesi domani quando è nato come si fa con
tutti i bambini lo abbiamo iscritto
all'anagrafe l'istat elaborando i dati
delle iscrizioni in anagrafe per nascita
trasforma il mio evento demografico
importante in una statistica demografica
e quindi mi permette ad esempio di
sapere che quanti sono i bambini che
sono nati nello stesso mese di giulio o
con quanti coetanei giulio condivide il
nome o se le mamme della provincia di
trento sono in media più giovani o meno
giovani di me ma la demografia è
importante anche perché ha importanti
conseguenze per le politiche pubbliche
e questo perché perché la demografia
cominci a possiede degli strumenti che
ci permettono di capire come cambierà
una popolazione perché cambierà e quali
sono le conseguenze del cambiamento
demografico
uno di questi strumenti è la previsione
demografica se vogliamo prevedere quanti
saremo tra vent'anni nel 2039
possiamo partire dalla popolazione di
oggi è invecchiata di vent'anni quindi i
ventenni di oggi saranno i quarantenni
del 2039 i quarantenni saranno i
sessantenni e così via
poi però abbiamo bisogno di tre
ingredienti il primo dobbiamo stimare
quante persone nasceranno da qui al 2030
9 dobbiamo poi stimare quante moriranno
nello stesso intervallo qui se volete
potete toccare ferro e infine dobbiamo
stimare quanti stranieri arriveranno nel
nostro paese e quanti italiani invece il
nostro paese lo lasceranno per
trasferirsi all'estero tra i tre le
migrazioni sono le più difficili da
stimare
perché dipendono da tantissimi fattori
per citarne alcuni guerre carestie crisi
economiche ai cambiamenti climatici
bene quindi quanti saremo nel 2039
secondo le nazioni unite
passeremo dai 7,7 miliardi del 2018 a
ben 9,1 miliardi nel 2039
e poi la popolazione continuerà a
crescere e raggiungere un plateau nei
decenni successivi 9,1 miliardi
ci possiamo fidare di questa previsione
beh innanzitutto occorre dire che questo
è il numero più plausibile ma in realtà
c'è un intervallo di incertezza che
diventa sempre più ampio quanto più è
lontano l'anno che vogliamo prevedere e
poi per capire la bontà di una
previsione demografica possiamo andare
indietro nel tempo e vedere se le
previsioni che sono state fatte in
passato si sono avverate oppure no
ad esempio
nel 1958 le nazioni quando quando la
popolazione del mondo era pari a 2,8
miliardi
le nazioni unite stimarono che nel 2000
saremmo arrivati a 6,28 miliardi e ci
hanno preso quella previsione fatta nel
58 era di poco superiore al numero di
quanti effettivamente eravamo nel 2003
6,14 miliardi ma la popolazione mondiale
sta crescendo ma non è sempre stato così
anzi per una lunghissima parte della sua
storia la popolazione rimasta più più
piuttosto costante
poi ha iniziato a crescere sulla spinta
dello sviluppo della rivoluzione
industriale ha toccato il primo miliardo
circa nel 1800 e da lì in poi la
crescita della popolazione è stata
vertiginosa grazie a innovazioni in
campo medico tecnologico a miglioramenti
delle condizioni igienico sanitarie in
poco più di due secoli siamo passati da
1 a 7 miliardi e come abbiamo già detto
tra vent'anni supereremo il nono
miliardo
ma la popolazione non crescerà in modo
omogeneo ovunque nel mondo
vi faccio vedere come sarebbe la mappa
del mondo se invece di considerare
l'estensione territoriale dei paesi
considerassimo e la popolazione
allora nel mondo del futuro i paesi più
importanti saranno quelli dell'africa
sub sahariana l'india la cina già nel
2039 l'india avrà superato la cina come
paese più popoloso del mondo però
l'europa in questo quadro ci appare un
po diversa da come siamo abituati a
vederla e già perché la previsione ci
dice che l'europa avrà una popolazione
che realtà diminuirà in futuro e così
sarà anche la popolazione italiana
in effetti la popolazione italiana è già
in calo si stima che dai 60,6 milioni di
persone nel 2018
passeremo a 57,1 milioni nel 2039
quindi la popolazione italiana calerà le
cause di questa decrescita sono
tantissime la prima la più importante è
la bassa natalità tra le più basse in
europa in italia si fanno solo 1,3 figli
per donna e i figli arrivano sempre più
tardi in media quando la donna ha 32
anni dal 2016 i decessi superano i nuovi
nati e il flusso di immigrati
sebbene attenui un po la decrescita
della popolazione non è in grado di
contrastarla anche perché il numero di
quanti lasciano l'italia per trasferirsi
all'estero è in crescita soprattutto tra
i giovani ma
torniamo a come saremo nel 2039 nel 2039
saremmo saremmo tutti più vecchi
la scorsa estate era in voga condividere
una foto invecchiata di sé sui social
media
alzi la mano chi ha provato ad
invecchiarsi con face atto ecco bene
prendere se molti ok quindi una idea una
mezza idea di come saremo almeno
fisicamente tra 20 anni ce l'abbiamo
il fatto importante è che insieme a noi
anche il mondo invecchierà dal 2018 per
la prima volta nella storia dell'umanità
ci sono più anziani sopra i 65 anni che
bambini sotto i 5 anni ma ancora una
volta l'invecchiamento della popolazione
non avverrà in modo omogeneo ovunque nel
mondo
possiamo usare la piramide di
popolazione per capire meglio allora la
piramide di popolazione ci mostra la
struttura di una popolazione per sesso
ed età ci sono paesi come l'etiopia che
tra vent'anni saranno ancora
relativamente giovani qui i bambini
rappresentano la classe d'eta piu
numerosa e al crescere dell'età
la piramide diventa si assottiglia
sempre di più poi ci sono paesi come
l'italia
già che invecchieranno un bel po invece
tra vent'anni
qui sono i sessantenni settantenni a
rappresentare la classe più numerosa
della popolazione in italia oggi per
ogni dieci persone in età lavorativa ci
sono quattro anziani sopra i 65 anni nel
2039 per ogni dieci persone in età
lavorativa
ci saranno sette anziani sopra i 65 anni
allora è facile capire come
l'invecchiamento della popolazione avrà
importanti implicazioni per le politiche
pubbliche
basti pensare all'inevitabile aumento di
spesa pubblica per pensioni sanità
all'aumento dell'età pensionabile ma
questi numeri hanno implicazioni anche
per le nostre vite
per esempio per gli spazi che
frequenteremo le persone che
incontreremo
poi ci sono implicazioni anche per le
aziende perché il cambiamento perché
l'invecchiamento della popolazione
vuol dire che il mercato degli anziani e
in continua espansione con le relative
conseguenze
ma veniamo ora a noi quanti di voi hanno
60 anni
alzate la mano secondo l'istat
vivrete in media altri 26 anni in media
tra circa sei anni potrete andare in
pensione vi rimangono quindi 20 anni di
tempo libero che cosa farete con tutto
questo tempo
magari vi rimetterete a studiare o
continuerete a lavorare farete i nonni a
tempo pieno
farete volontariato ci avete mai pensato
e invece quanti hanno vent'anni
bene tra voi è probabile che più donne
che uomini conseguono la laurea è
probabile che formerete coppie in cui le
donne sono più istruite degli uomini è
probabile che convive rete invece o
prima di sposarvi se avete mai pensato
ecco quindi che quando ci chiediamo come
sarà il nostro futuro
inevitabilmente ci chi ci pensiamo agli
eventi demografici che ci accadranno eh
già perché la demografia e fatta dai
nostri individuali corsi di vita siamo
noi la demografia altro che una noiosa
lista di statistiche quelle statistiche
servono alla demografia permetterci in
mano una chiave di lettura ma per
decifrare come cambierà il mondo intorno
a noi perché quanti saremo quanti anni
avremo e dove vivremo influenzerà anche
come vivremo nel 2039 il cambiamento
demografico è un ingranaggio alla base
dei cambiamenti sociali economici e
tecnologici che avverranno da qui al
2030 9 e oltre perciò
la prossima volta che sentirete una
statistica sulla popolazione o sentirete
parlare di demografia aguzzate le
orecchie perché vi interesserà grazie
[Applauso]